so there is also a number of very
interesting
startups and different brands that work
in a microbiome in the beauty and some
companies like s biomedic symbiome
dermala
they focus on specific conditions and
develop
solutions to address acne rosacea skin
aging and skin health
there were other companies like skin
trust Dr elza jungmung some of them also
have products but what they also do they
sell
direct to Consumer microbiome tests
and actually unlike uh I think genetics
data human genetics data here people are
really willing to share their skin
microbiome taser
so it's a big business for these
companies
uh to
kind of educate consumers on their skin
microbiomes but at the same time
obviously to collect the data because in
addition to skin microbiome
these companies collect lots of other
information on lifestyle demographic
skincare conditions and so on so it's
very uh interesting business and we will
see soon
some
insights I think from these companies
that's another company Dr Elsa Youngman
they also sell direct to Consumer tests
they collect data
and they also have a very good skin care
products
another company I want to mention I
briefly mentioned it before is s
biomedic
it's a company based in Belgium they
have very interesting live probiotic
Solutions and they did
I think 15 clinical trials according to
their website
and published several papers for example
one of the papers here talks about
transplantation of skin microbiome
and basically they were inspired by
studies on gut microbiomodulation
and then decided to use similar
technique to transplant the skin
microbiome from somebody who was
suffering from severe acne sorry to that
person from a person who has a healthy
skin and the results are really really
interesting so basically
within a week
the recipient
was the recipient's microbiome was
similar to the one from the donor so
really interesting approach
developing life probiotics and skin
microbiome transplants
so um
this is a game review
by scientists from L'Oreal
they talk about
microbiome translations in the beauty
industry and in addition to
robust in silico and in vitro tests
Regulatory and safety approvals
formulation expertise for the in
Incorporated performance and so on what
they mention here is that
we need deeper knowledge of cost
microbiome interactions in order to
understand what's going on and in order
to really being able to
uh modulate it and affect it and again
they also ask the question on what is
the cause versus what is the effect we
need data for that but in addition to
that we need kind of clever thinking and
I presented a couple of examples
of computational approaches that address
this very important questions but of
course there is a lot to be done here
and um
there are lots of opportunities and some
challenges
where we can harness microbiome for the
beauty industry
again it's the citizen science people
are willing to share the data and the
data is very easy to collect and then we
can analyze it uh and make some
conclusions there are already many
publicly available data sets
uh really quite a few data sets you know
you can just find and use to develop
your own
applications and insights that run
databases that in addition with the data
sets can also be utilized to make new
discoveries
and of course there are challenging
problems waiting to be sold
and one of them is actually making
predictions evaluating skin and hair
conditions and diseases identifying
so-called Derma types
another challenge is to identify new
molecular targets and solutions
developing new ingredients
from microbiome they're metabolize
and then already mentioned uh it's very
important and actually crucial to
understand the interactions between host
genetics and transcriptomics on one hand
with microbiome on the other hands
another promising direction is to
understand fungal microbiome or
microbiome this is how it's called and
also to conduct
smart trials on how to modulate
microbiome in order to achieve desired
results